wade lightheart
welcome great to be here thanks for
having me thanks so much for coming on
the program
yeah the program right she just gave
birth to a new universe or something
with that countdown
boom boom
we have a epic show consciousness
metaphysics
biochemistry bio-optimization
all of the insanity of
the chemo electroconnectomics that are
happening in our
nervous system and how it affects our
perception
how it affects our enlightenment how it
affects our peak performance
so damn pumped for this and me too yeah
yes wait
let's just jump into the
fundamental questions that you and i
have discovered are most
salient to the nature of reality and
experience
which are questions like what is
the i or what is
source or what is this reality what is
infinity
let's start with your thoughts about
things like that
well i think it's always evolving um
and it's
very hard to determine since
it's that's an a non-linear and unusual
way to kind of approach life when we've
been conditioned to a newtonian paradigm
causality-based reality that has been
infused into the
neurosynaptic connections of her mind
which create a pattern recognition
system that self
affirms our own biases so
that's a tough one however
um i'll share with you where i'm at
in the spectrum of those considerations
at this moment
and i would say that
if we going back to david hawkins who i
think has given us the
the best approximation of the
stratas of potential realities in this
conscious domain experienced through the
human nervous system
so i think we the common elements that
we can
state with relative
certainty is that the general point of
reference for most
people as an eye would be me
the protoplasmic biochemical
being which is attached to a name
identification um
you know a bunch of quantifiable
measurements by a generally agreed set
of rules
weight height hair color eye color
heart resting heart rate all the bio
hacking markers that everybody's
tracking and getting excited about these
days
so that's one point so that's a
perceptual thing from which most people
are going to observe their life however
with the investigation which is
consciousness research so what you're
getting at is that determining the
nature of consciousness itself
i would say okay we're using
the kind of reasoning points that
hawkins i think laid out quite
eloquently and that is
well if i can experience my arm
but if i cut my arm off i'm still me
because my other arm i'm still me
if i cut my other leg off and my other
leg off i'm still me
so the eye which is experiencing my
arm my legs or the lack thereof
is associated with the protoplasm on a
certain level so then you go wait a
second well we're having this
conversation and i can see my thoughts
okay so if i can witness my thoughts i'm
not my thoughts either and if i can have
emotions and feelings okay i feel happy
sad whatever
i'm witnessing these experiences
and so whether i'm referencing uh
a pleasure or pain point or an
attraction or aversion
in my protoplasmic self
or in my intellectual or emotional self
all of those are still going to the
filter of the eye which is sometimes
referred to the ego
um if someone's really diving into
meditation um contemplative
aspects uh you know simulation theory
or psychedelics or some combination of
all because most people would
will investigate all of those realms
in their pursuit of quote unquote truth
or what is
what is the eye of i and i would say
that the
the i that one
experiences tends to expand
in the research until one
comes quite clear
that it is but a drop of the ocean
of all that is so what we
consider our life or our experiences is
very much like a water droplet
falling into the ocean and before
when the drop hits it hasn't dissolved
in the ocean so imagine
coming into physical existence this
realm this medium the strata
we'll consider that an ocean and you
could call that an electromagnetic ocean
if you will
and the the drop point into physical
reality is the drop
which some people would refer to the
soil a soil
soul breaking into the plane of the
ocean of consciousness itself
and for a brief period of time which we
call our lifespan
that is the separation of the drop from
the
ocean and what we would call
our quote-unquote death would be the
dissolution of that ego structure which
we would call the small eye
into the large i which is the total
observational component which binds
everybody everything and everything in
the universe that's how i would
determine that at where i'm at right now
i love it when our guests hit back
tennis balls
that to these questions where there's
an obvious amount of study across many
of these
concepts and frameworks and
understandings from everything
of the mystic traditions and
spirituality
all the way up to electromagnetism
and the chemoelectroconnectomics and
sort of the
understanding of the levels of
consciousness
upgrading from an egoic state to an
enlightened state
it's really important that people see
the politi
in what you shared that your polymath
you've learned much across many
disciplines
and how that's actually created
a more refined
understanding for you of what
the nature of reality is and then that
translates as you go all the way inward
to that source
it translates into a pragmatic
utilitarian value of
as you go outward artistically with
bio-optimizers and everything that
you're bringing to our world
that what's happening is that
you bring that unique
firework expression
with a high level of morality a high
level of ethics
maximizing human potential in this
dreamed
reality and so that's a critical
component the pragmatic the utilitarian
value of going all the way to source to
know yourself
know what you know what the reality is
and so
it's always uh refreshing when the
tennis balls are hit back
as such and david hawkins has been a
massive influence on
myself and many others that we've had on
the show now and i'm really glad that
you brought him up and you've had
several other important spiritual
teachers which we'll probably talk about
here in a bit
the question that i would probably ask
you
next around this topic would be
something like
is this an appearance of infinity
would seem as such
and then another question to ask is
that
if this is an appearance of infinity
therefore we will never come to an end
well that's certainly an attractive
concept
and i think the addiction to not coming
to the end
is what keeps the cycle of incarnations
and maintains
the the
very thin layer between the drop in the
ocean until eventually one sees the
futility of all that
another important bit here to play with
you on
is when you have enlightened parents
the ego doesn't form i'd be curious to
hear your thoughts about this
ignorant parents will have the infant as
it becomes a toddler and a child become
attached to their ego their identity
being finite trying to seek happiness
and peace in the maya in the material
illusory world whereas an enlightened
parent
would have their child recognize
themselves
as an expression of infinity and
also as a unique contributory
firework in this dream and so therefore
in an enlightened parent do you see the
process of sort of
the ego not ever even forming
and so that the infant stays at that
level of enlightenment throughout
its trajectory to adulthood well i think
there's
a considerable amount of assumptions in
that statement that
could probably taken part by
observational realities
and that there are
there's number one there's an assumption
that an enlightenment is concordant with
the parents
we don't know if that's true number two
we don't know actually what the state of
enlightenment
is and then number three we're assigning
causality to the concept of
enlightenment
and the choices which then somewhat
contain
a moral and ethical judgment of what is
enlightened parented versus not
at this present time relative to this
physiology
physical reality i'm not a parent so i'm
not
able to comment with any level of
experiential subjective experience and
so i would only be
you know crafting up ideas for the
audience which are not really my
experience
fair
i'm curious as to how you play
with the simultaneity across
the different
schools of thinking that have evolved
over the last million
excuse me thousands of years millennia
where you have a very
non-dualism approach where
there's a immediate recognition
that the eye is illusory that
the absolute or ultimate realization has
to do with the absolute
perfection or wholeness of what already
is
as these appearance is happening and
then
in the dualism which you can hold
simultaneously as that non-duality
would be something like there is a
electromagnetic
rhythmic balanced interchange that's
happening there is like in the yin and
yang there is
ignorance and there is knowledge or
liberation
and that somebody that's in that egoic
bubble is ignorant and somebody that is
in an enlightened state as has
knowledge vidya nvidia
and then also simultaneity with the
individuation
although the individual is an illusion
and a dream
at the same time it is a unique
expression
a unique firework and so the west is not
wrong
in that sense so how do you feel about
the non-duality the dualism the
individuation holding them
simultaneously
yeah it's a dance
it's represented as a dance in many
cultures and many things or
way or yeah you know the dance of shiva
or
right whatever you choose it's been
interpreted many ways
relative to cultural norms and values
and
about three and a half years ago i did a
deep dive
um on a plant medicine journey on
the the start of the conversation which
you referred to which is
is the conceptual ideologies that are uh
held in mind with civilizations and i
have been working on that particular
thought process for the last three and a
half years about the
ascending and descending aspects of
the various civilizations throughout
history their
beliefs and values and
whether they went sideways and
exterminated or they simply rose and
fall like a natural crested wave and
at every point you can always make a
judgment or an assessment and say that
was
you know the downfall of that society
but if you ascribe to physics
where there is the law of entropy and
centropy
so both depending on the time
perspective that
in order for you know the more
pessimistic view would say that all
ordered systems
descend into chaos and the optimist
view would say yes that's true but if
you stay pay attention long enough they
reorganize into more complex beings
and then if you take from simulation
theory
where people say if you even run a
simulation on a computer with a
relatively simple
uh paradigm of
you know mutation all of a sudden things
get very complex out of
not that far down the road and within
that complexity patterns begin to emerge
of super unintelligent components which
now
start to exhibit a kind of
localized intelligence which we could
call tribal or
national or international or
you know exoplanet or consciousness or
deification or
you can kind of move through whatever
strata that you so choose
if you want to look at you know it's
kind of like
are we in the middle somewhere between
something very very big and something
something very small it would seem that
way
so again i think ultimately point of
reference is everything
and that we're just kind of bouncing
around in this giant electromagnetic
field
with a point of reference of convenience
as an
incarnated component relative to this
uh sensory realm which we experience
which so the human body has a sensory
uh parameter built
into it their five senses and then
combined with intuitive nature
but we know that there is all sorts of
matter and
energy and frequency which are not
detectable by our human senses we can
use an infrared camera for example which
we don't necessarily pick up but it's a
real and
you know you get into matter and dark
matter and you know and i think
it all bases is that as long as one is
approaching everything from this
perspective of dualism
dualistic uh thinking that there is a
light and a dark in a and and it's
diversification of either a negative or
positively charged
ion and or
the fluctuations on a sine wave if you
want to go to a wave or
to a light quanta as which is both a
particle and a wave
in a substrate of nothingness which
that's an interesting thing in itself
the concept of nothing itself
or void yeah right and so then you have
void
and then allness which is the
differentiation between
hinyana buddhism and mahayana buddhism
so
it's it's completely subjective and
arbitrary to
deciding on where you want to go with it
and who you want to hang out with and
and ride with those collective beliefs
but if you go to
the devotional non-duality with people
that have
more of well-being as a focus rather
than suffering so
that's sort of where the dualism can in
a sense be something that
we incorporate in our
process that we gravitate
towards what is maximizing well-being
and prosperity and less around ego and
suffering
well if you break down prosperity
what does that really mean and that
means i would say
is the capability of accessing
a wider range of choices
from an experiential reality so that
could be economics that could be
consciousness that could be physical
capabilities
but i would say i would over the
overarching generalization of prosperity
as be
hey let's have more choices as opposed
to less
so you would focus in on choice
architecting
maximizing that yes that's how i would
associate it uh
because an expanded level of
consciousness is basic
needs met you're able to have larger
choice architecture well
i i don't even think that you know basic
needs
certainly i think water food energy
shelter
correct which is relative to this plane
but there's there's a built-in
assumption that this plane
is the ultimate place to be but since
everybody leaves here
there's good indication that that's not
the case this is more
of a temporary experience and that at
some point
the system ops us out of it and if one's
an
optimist then we would say that oh well
that's because
there's some benevolent aspect of this
that says you know what human suffering
can only go on so line and you need a
reprise
before you go back if you so choose
and most of the spiritual texts are the
world
talks about that whether it's the
prodigal son
or the reincarnations into buddhahood or
whatever
the eastern or western doctrine that you
choose to
engage in in your process of
self-discovery it's like well
they all kind of agree on a couple of
things and that is
that this is a temporal experience and
that there are realms
both of in both directions on the
paradigm of stuff
suffering and so you decide through your
actions choices and attention
of what direction you're gonna go and so
i
tend to think that most
um spiritual
laws or rules or uh suggestions
are not made to control and condemn
although in some of the institutional
components that they've
definitely been used with that but in
its absolute practice in an individual
i think it leads to an expansion of
choices as opposed to a restriction
which is sometimes
indoctrinated inside a religious you
know fundamentalism and so i'm against
going too deep inside of those
components so it's kind of like what
bruce lee say i don't believe in styles
right
right take what works and discard what
doesn't and that is the pathway i think
david hawkins ascribed to in his uh
devotional non-duality devotion to the
truth no matter what
good i'm glad that you got here because
i interrupted when you were
hitting into this devotional non-duality
bit on the david hawkins
so devotion to the truth no matter what
yes
yep that produces
its own flowers that yields its own
bountiful
love and harmonics
would you say that you mentioned earlier
there was a process of
indicating that we're not sure what
enlightenment is
would it be fair to say that we can make
a
small map
as we discuss where we say that as
in the sargasso maharashtra said i am
not the body
and then we kind of go to the step okay
if i'm not the body
i'm the awareness or i'm the sky
in which the cloud of the body and the
experiences and emotions and thoughts
happen
okay so i'm that awareness i'm the sky
so our level of subtlety has increased
away from the appearance of matter and
form towards something that is
consciousness towards awareness
what is eternal and what is shared
and then even just like in our dream at
night when we
simulate out a reality and we immerse
ourselves in it as an observer
even the observer itself is dreamed even
the awareness
itself is a product of source or of
infinity
yeah and so is that how you sort of view
the structure
it's hard to determine because
we have the limitation of languaging and
i think that language
is a very poor cousin to experience and
you know um if you look at
i think the ultimate mystics which talk
about the the ultimate is
uh indescribable and non-definable
right so all by the act of
attempting to define it in one of those
things i immediately lose that which
what it is
right everybody knows what love is but
try and describe it people been singing
songs about it for thousands of years
but no one's quite got it right but
everybody knows what it is when one
experiences it
and in a sense that's also what is meant
by
that non-duality that
devotion to truth just being present
right here right now as an appearance
and yet there's also this
simultaneously a recognition that
if i experience anger i
don't want to experience that because i
butterfly affect that out onto my
friends and family
and i would rather feel happiness
and so then that's where the dualism
also
is embedded just like in the tiju by
doomy thousand years ago you have the
monist
and you have the dualist ian yang inside
of it
and that's the simultaneity
i agree the ineffability is really a
critical component of
it and yet
at the same time
recognizing that one of the coolest
things we can do is try
and use symbols to describe the
ineffable
do you feel that way well sure i think i
think part of the
joy of being in a human form and to
communicate with others
is to kind of come to some sort of
concordance as to
where are we what's going on and what's
the what's the general
accepted rules of the engagement here
and then from that start
extracting a variety of experiential
realities
and one may be
you know connected with someone for only
a few moments yet have a profound impact
and someone could be around someone for
most of their life and
feel almost nothing like maybe yeah you
get on the bus
the same bus driver every day to go to
work and he's the same bus driver
driving that thing for 35 years and you
interact with them on a very temporal
point but whatever
yet at one point you meet quote unquote
your your
hero or muse or
someone like that in a brief instant and
you carry that
impact of what they said maybe a line
maybe a statement
for the rest of your life yep
so
yeah you know you can go a lot of
different ways with those
kind of components and i i think you
know
not one to go out and dispense
advice but
it would seem that most people who
quote unquote go all in
and whatever they are derive a certain
biochemical reward system
that provides some sort of
cycle of repetitive influence however if
it becomes an
addiction then it becomes also
you can get an an unregulated aspect of
uh experiencing a certain vibration so i
think it's
normal to kind of move through all the
variants
at some thing that we call the
expression of
time or perceptual changes
due to new information or a changing set
of parameters and
there does seem to be a eureka aha
totally reward based system that's built
into our biology which therefore is in
the fabric of the universe so one would
lead to believe that the expansion of
consciousness
and into experience is something that's
innate within
consciousness itself is what causes
curiosity in the driving and the reward
system from that
so that's beautifully said so i think i
think we can i think we can go down that
road
as opposed to a nihilistic component
that nothing means anything
totally totally very seldom leads to
anyone
feeling generally good for the time that
they're here
so i think we kind of come full circle
to answer
your question but i do believe that
there may be some value of experiencing
that which isn't joyful and rewarding as
a point of reference
to to reignite the attraction to the
expansion
of consciousness almost as though
infinity
uses the nervous system
as a voyager
in the endless
exploration and
that we can get addicted to even the
abiding in infinity
and because there are biochemical
rewards that occur in that process
and that the
the tantric path or the boot
buddha's middle way or ramuna maharishi
sahaja samadhi
that we also
get the biochemical rewards when we
actually
weave the profound realizations
into the social fabric itself
and that there is almost no greater
service as ramanu maharshi said that you
can render
humanity than undergoing the process of
know thyself recognize yourself as
infinity expressing itself
god realize self realize source realize
and as in many of the analogies then the
moth
gets zapped by that white source light
the contracted egoic
sugar cube dissolves in the hot tea of
infinity and then as you
go outward in expression it's more
harmonic
it's more in balance with nature with
love
and enlightenment and maximizing human
potential
yeah that seems to be the
as the sufi metaphysic goes only the
ignorant seek what is already there
and yet it remains for you to recognize
it
and that sort of brings together the
non-dualism with the dualism into one
you're already it but yet it remains for
you to recognize that you're already it
and so this just being an appearance
of this wade lightheart character slash
unit talking to this atlas character
slash unit on this
formed appearance of the simulation
youtube channel
that claims to be disseminating content
around enlightenment
i mean just that just sort of interrupt
but i mean what people are listening to
right now
is a is a simulation of the conversation
that's already happened
so they're not even experiencing the
conversation in real time relative to us
there is a simulated reality that
they're watching
on video or listening in this auditorial
program
which becomes replicated over the amount
of people who download or listen to that
so um and beautiful by as such
the listener who's listening to this
right now you're within this room
outside of the time construct of the
present moment
and have arrived here at the perfect
time by your own design
yes so beautifully when you when you
realize that that
you me the listener the viewer
are intimate intimately connected
through an aspect of consciousness
that is not limited to both the narrow
present
and we use currently technology
to um time distort that
out of a matter of convenience
however i believe that
and and i i actually have personal
experience
of this reality so i'm not i'm not
stating this from a sense
of uh conjecture or ideation but as an
experiential reality that
in yogananda's book autobiography of a
yogi
he wrote something that was so almost
cryptically hidden within the pages and
that is
the contemporaries of a spiritual master
are not limited to the narrow present
and
that's not a conceptual idea for myself
it's an experiential reality
and i think what most of us are seeking
who begin the journey
into the ideation of that reality
is to seek the experiential reality and
therefore one would say that
consciousness
choose to experience in its relative
limited physical experience on itself
until it seeks to go back to the ocean
again so the drop
although apprehensive about its
dissolution into the ocean of spirit
is also attracted to it therefore
there's nothing to fear from it
because fear is the basis of all
restriction of why someone wouldn't
engage in that on some level and there
might be a whole bunch of structures
around that
and it's the fear that the show is going
to end for me the wave
the eye right and that is the egoic
attraction which all mystics say that we
need to surrender to become
one with the absolute which we would
call enlightenment itself
i love the perennial wisdom it's many
paths
one end all these different
incredible faces on the mountain
all to the same top
this attachment this
amkara in sanskrit we get this egoic
layers of identity i am this body
i am this finite appearance of form i
must extract
happiness from the world of form
and that all of these mystic traditions
surrender surrender surrender the layers
of identity surrender
the body going deeper into the layers of
subtlety into awareness
go into that sky like space
like being that then you
become the witness the observer of the
clouds
and then recognize that even that
witness observer awareness itself is an
agent of source
and that you'll never come to the end of
exploration that's what eternal is when
you look
all the way to the left and you're like
eternity
and you look all the way to the right
and you're like
eternity and this
is an appearance
and there's no beginning there's no end
drop the attachment to the appearance
recognize that going all the way inward
all the way to that source is critical
for the dissolving of the egoic
contraction that then
ends up serving you and your family and
your friends and your community and the
world
at the absolute highest morality
so yeah this seems to be the
core beautiful yeah
first chunk of the convo i love that bit
that was so fire
i love that and now actually this is a
great segue because
what i would like to play with you on
next
is what we just talked about in the
first chunk
there is a we mentioned this a couple
times throughout but there's a
biochemical component to what we talked
about
correct and so this would be a good way
to sort of
explain okay i'll i'll give it a
framework and then you can tell me
what you feel about the framework and
then plug in some of the
the bio optimizer's optimization
into it if it resonates so for me
a lot of the framework that we just
discussed
has to do with the
the inward component the inward
component meaning to recognize yourself
as
source or infinity expressing itself and
then the outward component
is sort of the optimization of
entrepreneurship
or science or creativity these types of
things
as like a unique firework in this
appearance yeah and so
now my question would be then would you
explain to us the
bio optimizer's biochemical optimization
on both the inward process and the
outward
sure process yeah okay and we can pull
items as we go all
sure so let's look at our nervous system
structure because that is how we
determine
the sensory experience of our world and
our ability to activate
um awareness or consciousness or thought
patterns
into physical expressions whether that's
movement
the aspects of thinking or the aspects
of
sensing whether it's taste touch smell
sight
you know and then you get into the more
refined intuitive
aspects so all those
have a commensurate level of
neuronal connections in other words
there's an axion and a dendrite that
connect up in a certain pattern
with a concordant biochemical
associative set of neural chemicals
signature in a sense
yeah so for example the the refined
movements of a grand master in chess
have a certain
synaptic pattern which would be
different from say
an nfl running back which would be
different from a ballerina which would
be different
from a painter who paints your house
but all of those have a habitual pattern
of neurosynaptic connections concordant
with a neurochemical
sea of neurotransmitters which go along
with it
and so we are able to generate the
neural synaptic connections through
repetition and training which is
a background that i had through exercise
science and that you lift these weights
to do these things and
you increase the strength and
connectivity of
very certain patterns of firing which
relate to the development
of skills or the development of physical
tissue right okay
so that's one aspect and the second
aspect is that we
this is optimized by the neurochemistry
from which we're able to manufacture
from
our metabolic systems and organs
and then the delivery systems which make
them
operate and it would be safe to say
that i would say in the last
80 years or so
we have since the dropping of the
nuclear bomb on japan after world war
ii and the rise of the uh electoral
communication
atomic age which is
you know after that after the war
there was a massive connection between
various components of society there was
the
transport of goods and services in
people to expose
ideas and various chemical components
the discovery of the double helix that
kind of
stuff of course but also just just
shipping and communication
totally you know hey i can get coffee
from south america i can get oranges
from florida and i can get
you know tea from china and you know i
can get
you know cars from detroit through
barges on the ocean yeah
right so all of a sudden there was a
rapid expansion and exposure of
of of cultural available
from the processes of
many millions of years of evolution
into a rapidly expanding technological
intervention and although many of those
breakthroughs have certainly uh made
life
extraordinary almost mystical to someone
just a hundred years ago
you know who were riding around on
horses and very few people had
you know in-house plumbing live
streaming of video podcasts
yeah through time and space on their own
broadcasting i mean it's pretty far out
what's happened in the last hundred
years
but concordia to that there's a lot of
unintended consequences and those
unintended consequences are we disrupt
the natural food supply
supply chain uh to meet a rapidly
growing poly
population which has been expanded
through the advent of pharmaceuticals
which altered the the evolutionary
patterns from darwinian evolutionary
components you know for example
when antibiotics came out people just
died of infection from wounds but then
antibiotics come out and all of a sudden
there is
you know a massive expansion of the
growth of population because
the um sub optimal
immune systems were not weeded out
through natural selection that they were
supported artificially if one could say
that but no one could argue that was the
natural expression and so we've got to
this experiment
but we're far enough along the
experience experiment by third
generation
that it's undeniable that there's some
consequences to technological innovation
that we didn't anticipate and i would
say that our capacity
to convert what we consume and so
there's the definition of food what is
it what's required of it
i think our incomplete definition of
that food has left
disastrous results as well as the
assumption that we
assimilate that food in an optimal way
and deliver it so that we can
manufacture the neural chemicals that
allow for the optimal
development of axion dendrit connections
and so where i come into the picture
you're really bringing agriculture and
food
into right the technological evolution
of the species along right to the answer
to the question
right so going back to our awareness and
experience of reality or conscious or
the ability to go for it is often
concordant with a neural connective
physiology as well as the neurochemical
components and so one
can um if one has
the good fortune to be able to be
cognizant
of one's existent and the ability to
select stimuli that enhance
that experience which for a great number
of people that's not an
option yeah which we would like to have
empathy and compassion for
which you also mentioned choice
architectures right it's critical to
this
right so therefore us that does have
that choice needs to express that to the
maximum capabilities
as a benevolent person because there
seems to be
more advantages to synergistic
operational paradigms than than to be
reduction to there's only me and all
that's matters and so i think
our bio chemical feedback system leans
to
connectivity as opposed to you know
separation
and my role in that
journey as a co-founder of
bio-optimizers
through my own experiential reality as a
former bodybuilder and as that
an exercise physiologist and a
nutritionist is to recognize
that we've deviated um i would say
unintendedly i'm not going to say it's a
conspiracy
some people might say that it is but
i think it's pretty clear that for most
of the population
do not have the capabilities and i think
this is a dwindling capability amongst
the population at large
to access um the full spectrum
of neurochemical pop possibilities in
all of their physiology
especially their neural chemistry
which limits the amount of
conscious and physical options that they
have
and when you have a severe impairment of
those
um options we call that disease
and when we see and a massive expansion
of those possibilities we call that
enlightenment and so
the role that i play in this journey we
call life
is to help discover the components that
optimize the conversion of our food
into these vast array of neurochemicals
and physiological structures
and to share with people the things that
i've been able to do to expand the
choices i have today which are far
greater than what i had when i was say
20.
likewise okay so just to hit the ball
back here it would be
it would be something like the focus on
the input that then
creates the
biochemistry and choice
that makes it more democratized
for people to be able to and optimize
for people to be able to go all the way
in
and all the way out yes okay yeah and
not just the s so there's a there's a
there's an element of assumption though
that's built into the nutritional
paradigm
that i'm i'm really
i think is where the origin story of by
optimizers came from
and that is the assumption that if i put
something in my mouth that is
immediately
uh broken down and and and converted
into the elements that allow for that
full range of possibility
so assumption most of nutrition is
focused on well what are those elements
those base elements that get re
constituted inside our system
but i would look and then and then the
detoxers per se are saying well what
contaminants are disrupting that process
and then where by optimizers comes in is
actually how do we increase the amount
of workers the converters
to making the transition whether you're
using a supplement or a base food
or a concocted you know biochemically
advanced composite nutrition product
through
you know science and chemistry or
whatever but at the same at
the end point we don't make the
assumption on the conversions which most
people do
and so by optimizers optimizes first
the conversion process through the use
of enzymes and
probiotics which in my biological
observations seem to be the only
catalyst of that conversion which is
enzyme
catalyst correct
and probiotics being in uh i would say
like
individualize mobilized catalyst
organizations much more like you would
say road crews that are going out and
patching up the road
so they are primarily they catalyze
certain chemical transactions in the
human body because we are living in a
symbiotic relationship
with these organisms which for much of
society have been eradicated
unintentionally through the use of
antibiotics
the prolific use of antibiotics so which
first gave a benefit
through allowing the expansion of life
by
restricting people dying from disease
has also
wiped out a whole cascade of these
workers
which are now causing a limitation to
the potential expressions of
neurochemistry in its concordant states
of consciousness and awareness
and so my job and what we do in the
company is to
optimize that conversion and then
optimize
the development uh directly
of the neurochemistry itself and that's
where we're at in
kind of the journey that myself and my
co-founder on right now
again it's just the same response for me
to the first answer that you gave to the
first question
because you can tell again by studying
across all of these different
disciplines
it's made you very polymathic to be able
to address this
from again we talk about this so much on
the program but go all the way to the
source
go all the way to the most upstream way
to tackle the downstream
and so again the most upstream that you
talk about is this recognition of the
input you know if there is a process
over
millennia of developing a very specific
style
of input around the
choices that become available to us
biochemically on that inward and outward
trajectory and then in the last 100 or
so years
there's this massive transition to a
very
monoculture to a very antibiotic
to a very technologically
where you feel like you know you're
staring at a computer screen for eight
hours that that
obviously and you know crunching over
like this there are
all of these if you're not actually
going out and
bathing in the sun and in the air you
know you're going to have
these pathologies build up and
create less choice architecture for the
inward and for the
outward expression and so i love that
first principle
approach to it and then another
potentially good way to address this
would be something like
where would you and your co-founder
where would you guys
and your company leverage
enzymes and probiotics given
2021 and beyond we're heading into these
you know these roaring 20s the 2020s and
we're gonna just be piling on
biotechnology neurotechnology artificial
general intelligence just
parsing all of this data with and i know
bio optimizers has their
sort of path with the personalization
component as well to it
but so okay so you have this wade
lightheart unit and it has a very
specific
composition uh it has a very specific
lineage that it came from
with its familial trajectory as well as
it has its very specific
you know thousand bacteria species
in the gut symbiosis and so
now how do you leverage both
enzymes and probiotics how do you figure
out
in these roaring 20s how to leverage
those for both the inward
actualization realization as well as for
the outward
unique expression how do you how do you
figure out what optimizes that process
yeah it's a great question and it's an
ongoing research
and so um i don't
want to state that we all absolutely
know all of those things but i can
give reference to my own journey as
first a bodybuilder and someone who
disrupted my digestive system on a
performance-based diet which was
concordant to aesthetics
which ended up compromising my health
and then ultimately discovering the
principles the con that the
the issue was my ability to convert
which i was consuming on a performance
diet into those
chemicals without having uh
consequential residual waste or
like burning dirty gas if you will and
so by
adding a vast array of throwing more
workers at the problem i was able to
reverse
the downward trend that happened after
my mr universe contest in 2003 when
after the contest which i reached the
pinnacle of aesthetic and performance
idealistic
in the world of bodybuilding yet uh had
sacrificed my health in a way that i
didn't uncomprehend until i gained 42
pounds in 11 weeks
of fat and water going from mr universe
to mr marshmallow in a very short period
of time after
literally uh the devotion of that craft
for 16 years
and had it not been for the subsequent
you know 42 pounds in 11 weeks
yeah yeah and so if it hadn't been
for the intervention
of uh a good doctor michael
brian who was
as such a radical
positive of expression of possibility
that jarred my state of existence enough
to for me to buy into some of the
suggestions you made which were counter
to what i had got to the point
but he was of sufficient magnitude in
persona
and expression that i was willing to let
go
of what i was experiencing at that
moment in
to play with the ideas and suggestions
that he would and thank god i did and
both matt and i engaged in that process
with the our first experimental aspects
of
consuming super physiological dosages
of various strains of bacteria and
enzymes
and concordant uh nutritional paradigms
which were not present
in our current dietary practices and the
results
were absolutely clear certain
and definite and and it was so impactful
that during that phase we both decided
that we would dedicate our lives to not
only sharing that information
but the continued and ongoing pursuit of
ever
expanding possibilities by taking that
first step and going down
the rabbit hole or up the stairway to
heaven whichever way you want to call it
to our absolute expression as beings and
i think
to be to have the good fortune
to find that which it is that makes you
what it is that you
wish to express in this life is a great
gift
and that's why i love doing these things
and we you know we can go way
way way out there but at the fundamental
level someone listening to this and i'm
i'm going to make a suggestion
and that is
stop what you're doing right now
take a moment and pause and listen
get out a piece of paper if you want and
say are you experiencing
life to what you feel is its full
capacity and possibility
and if you are you don't need to listen
any further
you're good i have no value to offer you
if you think there is the potential
for a greater expansion of possibility
or that you feel somehow that your
suffering are limited
or not feeling what it could be then i
would invite you
view the suggestion that you are
suffering from neurochemical deficiency
caused by a disruption in the food
conversion as well as the production of
food that leads to an essential
full capabilities of generating a a far
more varied possibility matrix
so i'm 20 plus years in this journey and
i could say i haven't found a ceiling
to the potential and there seems to be a
point very much like peter thiel talks
about in zero to one in technological
geometric progressions
that that same if you look through fixed
systems in a digital reality which is
both the binary choice
our neurochemistry and biology fire a
far
greater expansion in geometric
possibilities
and so therefore one if one is really
honest about do i want to hook myself
into the limit binary possibility
expansion or do i want to access the
biochemical which may be able to
supersede geometric expansion over and
above
a an artificial intelligence driven
system
right now which many of us are
struggling with the fact has ai
actually taken over are we quote unquote
booting up the extermination of the
human species
are we involved in this asymmetric war
with other foreign nations who are
seeking out self-selection of
extermination of the population through
uh the the control of algorithmic
paradigms which make people believe that
you know
taking a vaccine or staying at home or
wearing a mask or
not going to work and producing energy
or value units in your society is a good
option
it would seem to say that right now
humanity
is on the threshold of buying into the
artificial intelligence lie whether that
was an unintended
foreign access or whether artificial
intelligence has taken over
a significant amount of human
intelligence on a geometric expansion to
create us all an enslavement
i think that we have to really
carefully consider the possibility
that we are enslaved by some form of
technology technology whether that's
biochemical or digital
that is leading us to feel less
expansive in our possibility matrix and
so i'm offering options and i do believe
that
chemistry by optimizing one's bio
biological chemistry and what we attempt
to do it by optimizing the vast array of
products and services that we offer
it gives a it's a potentiator
to other possibilities whether it's
developing new neural connective
realities
uh on a you know neuronal development in
your brain so that you can expand
consciousness or
express it or come to uh
acclimation with our temporal existence
and physical form
or whether it is to you know
topple what we see is the tyrannical
organizations which is suppressing that
i don't know
you get to you get to play the game the
way that you want
the recognition that the
choice architecture that the matrix of
possibilities
itself for
consciousness to be able to go all the
way inward towards its source and all
the way outward as its unique expression
and to be a part of the process where
that feels like it's constantly
expanding
is paramount rather than the at times
like you describe
it can feel like there's a contraction
when we read things like 50 or so
percent of
americans can't afford a 500 sudden
bill and that there's a bifurcation of
you go to wtf happened in 1971.com
a very clear bifurcation of what
happened between
median male income and real gdp
and so you just see this constant
increase in real gdp
in the us in the last 50 years median
meal income is flatlined so you wonder
you know also on a globalization level
what's happening with
the one percent what's happening with
the elite what's happening with
decentralization and cryptocurrencies
and entheogens and other sorts of
emerging markets that are trying to in a
sense
create an inclusive equity in the
growing pie for everybody create more of
that
choice architecture that is
more expansive driven by expansion
and then the style of being able to take
things like
the discoveries that you went through
in these last you know 18 or so now
years where there's a
there are enzymes and probiotics that we
can take
that create that expansionary
choice matrix that then enable us to
become more sovereign
in our biochemistry
whereas in the algorithmic ai driven
social fabric sometimes it feels like
there is
sometimes not as much of that
choice sovereignty and so almost as we
become more enlightened
all of the sort of geopolitical
fears they dissolve because we have more
enlightened leadership
we have more enlightened both top-down
and bottom-up style
architectures and so these are going to
be
keys to the both the inward and outward
so a good question potentially to ask
would be you know
i know the process is a constant
discovery but maybe we can go through
some of the products
that then enable the
inward and outward optimization because
you have some things that are very
best selling for a long period of time
so
there's this is a seven blend of
magnesium
and you said that this is in the last
couple of within the period of time we
were talking about maybe
80 or so years that there's been a
significant amount of magnesium stripped
away from
our intake correct and there's things
like that and there's things like in the
last
80 years we've seen a proliferation of
gluten intolerance correct
things like that and so this is gluten
guardian and then there's
there's a lot of of uh
kind of cognition boosting
both you know entrepreneurially executed
focus and there's also this you know
personalization around oh well
maybe there is a a relaxation
or an expansive component kind of like
what
magic mushrooms and entheogens provide
where you kind of merge with the
oceanic-ness
again so kind of maybe we walk through
and then sure
so so for the layman that's just coming
into this i went and i want to classify
um nutrition into a couple of elements
there are really
two components one is you're
delivering materials to construct the
physical form
or the chemicals which lead to a variety
of conditions in other words it's a
physical
and then so there's a manufacturing
quality or
you are converting whatever you're
consuming into
the energy to drive the power plants of
those conversions or those experiences
or those sensory perceptions so there's
the production of energy and there's
production of
materials which are constructed now the
intermediary of that
is enzymes and probiotics
which have been diminished extensively
through the process of technological
innovation over the last eight years so
the buddhist says when law started the
beginning and i would say humanity
is 80 years particularly because if you
look at what happened after the
if you look at post world war ii we had
the population started to move into
cities to produce
goods and services which were
transported and delivered around the
world through
uh the increase of marketing and
telecommunication and the desire hey i
want
you know pasta from italy or olives from
italy and i want oranges from florida
and i want coffee from south america and
cars from detroit
right and and that exchange and so the
united states became the manufacturing
the
the manufacturing center of the globe
and producing things and
we moved away from the british empire
which had dominated the realm
of uh productive capacity but being the
dominant currency of the world for 200
years
currency being a form of energy exchange
and then the united states came became
the manufacturing component and then
going back to your point in 1970
um the uh kissinger and the nixon
administration and i would say that
nixon was influenced by kissinger's
policies which is uh full cities trap
which they identified china as an
ascending power in in
america eventually the declining power
and thought if they could engage
with the chinese culture that if we
encourage them to a capitalistic
democracy and produced exorbitant amount
of benefits
through moving the manufacturing center
of the western hemisphere into chinese
china and through and not the one
percent through
ultra elite personages who were able to
leverage uh essentially a slave
class in china through an exorbitant
amount of
uh perverse incentives based in the
market
that eventually china would come around
and join us in the democratic
capitalistic which i think was a very
adolescent and naive concept considering
the chinese empire has existed somewhere
for five thousand years and there hasn't
been a
day of freedom within that structure
because it is still
a an empiric kind of concept which
denatured from the dynasties
into the maoist revolution which led to
his day which was the
separation of the idea of spirit and god
and
reality and now that
culture is according to their leader
chairman zee
looking to extend its dominion
throughout the entire world with their
philosophy and
whether they'll be successful or not um
i i personally think that
the kissinger administration and their
cronies
made a huge error and in doing so we
also
allowed for the advent of the
chemicalization and
and downward destruction of these the
essential components to the point that
the american individual at the emergency
hospital level
12 of the people are going
into emergencies due to gastrointestinal
issues related to the food that they're
consuming
so we so altered the production and
delivery of food through the advent
of nitrogen put on the soil to increase
crop yield
to deal with the people who are now
living in cities to crew support
manufacturing stuff and then
we move from manufacturing to servicing
the other manufacturing aspects of other
parts of the world
and now that services can be automated
through technological innovation there's
really no need for the american idea
right now if we can outsource
manufacturing at a fraction of the cost
and we can replace the service oriented
stuff with some form of artificial
intelligence from robotics there's
really no need for the united states on
the grand picture
so if you're looking at a grand concept
then is the eastern philosophy of order
over the western concept of freedom
or order and chaos as jordan peterson
might put for it
or masculine and feminine conceptuals if
you're looking for taoist philosophy
or light versus darkness who knows which
side of the equation is going to win out
in that but
where we intersect here as i would say
that if you took the grand
if you took a summation of say a
thousand
people a sample segment of society
it's without any
with a the briefness of observation
we are living at the highest form of
wealth
ever ever humanity has dicks
even the poorest person inside of the
western hemisphere
is radically wealthier
than almost anyone of a century before
when you you think of the access of
communication and technology and just
so the idea this propagated idea that
there are
winners and losers and victims of the
one percent first off the one percent
aren't the ones that are winning it's a
it's a micro fraction of that of some
epic proportion and i think plotting
this all
onto the one percent my experiences the
one percenters are the one that are
bringing
more wealth more value at a at a better
rate than others
and is the .001 on some sort of
diabolical plan i don't know i i
i tend not to i think it's not a good
idea to go down the conspiracy
component because then one becomes very
pessimistic it's a very attractive
component because then one can be placed
within their own victimhood of that
system and oftentimes will advent
radical changes and disruptions in
society and if we look at those
disruptions throughout history the rise
of the bolshevik revolution
in uh the soviet union right
the rise of nazism in
you know germany in last century uh the
and and the rise of the cultural
revolution in china
all of which resulted in at least a
hundred million people dying a world war
star
massive starvation and stuff one would
say that those ideologies are not the
direction that we want to go with our
canceled culture and these things and so
for us
the first step is we need to regain
the biochemical terrain within ourselves
so that we can consider
alternative possibilities to that which
we are being subjected to
through overt authoritarianism because
one can say that
in the last 250 years the american
experiment has created more value
and an increase in wealth not just here
in the united states but globally better
than any system
implemented to date and so many people
are so
quick to condemn the the the the the
aspects of society that isn't working
but they're they're
they're looking at the problem through a
very limited
lens of the narrow presence with no
historical reverence
or reference which is interesting
because that's exactly what
that's exactly what happened in china
when they did they took away
thousands of years of beautiful chinese
philosophy in this new
concept of atheistic uh
centralized control
and so one has to determine am i am i
here to be a human to experience the
separate
aspect of reality as an individual is
that of more value
or to be part of a electromagnetic grid
where i'm just another number another
peg
and if i get outside of that i'll be
swept out of the system
very much like a coder is going to
eliminate a virus
within the system or a bug in the
program and so which is more important
being the bug in the program or being
the
or being a peg
or a a zero or a one
inside the the matrix and so only the
individual can do that and i would
prefer
that we retain the possibility
of being the anomaly
as opposed to being the conformist and
the only way that i see that being
a possibility right now is if one is
able to
completely or twist a large degree take
control of their individual neural
chemistry
and physiology so that that possibility
is
even available to you because if you are
going to work and living in the kind of
technical limitation you can now live in
existence
today in the world and know nothing
about anything
other than the single function that you
are whether that is
you know putting the rubber on the
bottom of a sneaker whether that's
swiping something at a grocery store or
making lattes at starbucks or
looking at spreadsheets through your
computer to determine
the margin components for you know mega
biggie corp
all of those are a highly specialized
component which really doesn't have a
lot
to do with the expression of
consciousness itself and so therefore i
would say
that even though i'm very much
in love with many of the technological
integrations
we are at a point where i think a large
part of the population going back to
that sample set of a thousand people
are not experiencing joy and happiness
and the full range of emotional
capabilities
uh we're not we're seeing a moving away
from
uh standardized relationships and
intimacy
and uh socialization as humans tend to
be a very social animal so we
we've we've outsourced biochemical
connection
and in sourced a a technological digital
representation of connection
which i do not think sufficiently
fulfills the replication of more
biological organisms on the planet and
we've been sold that somehow
making more humans is a bad idea
and so it would seem that there is a
prevailing
uh concept that is being brought forth
into humanity
that the natural state of evolution and
the propagation and growth of our
species is somehow not good and i would
say that that's coming from a source
that is non-human which is developed
from these artificial
zero and one systems that is subjugating
us to
a a less than experience and so i hope
to reverse that trend and
and activate the rebels and activate the
the rage against the machine
and you know so i wouldn't say i'm the
one but i may be morpheus and suggesting
you know broadcasting as signals hey
you can take the red pill or the the
blue pill
and i'm going to show you how deep the
rabbit hole goes
i really appreciate the again the depth
of the perspective
and one of the fascinating components to
it that
i felt was a pretty in a sense a simple
way
of potentially understanding it is
something along the lines of just like
the style of as you were saying here on
the left is like
something that's a little bit more
conformity driven where every single
individuated firework
is some sort of a similar color similar
expression
and cog in a machine and then on this
individuated firework is a unique
color a unique expression a unique
potentially contribution a unique gift
and so
in many ways this reminds me of you know
the synthesis
of you know recognizing
in many ways the the east and the west
taking like a sorting algorithm you take
the
the best from both sides you take the
best from
the collectivist the best from the
non-duality the best from the
hyper spiritual and you merge that you
drain the dirty bath water
and you take from the west you take the
hyper individuation you take the
the benefits of the scientific method
and you take the benefits from
the unique artistic expression of each
individuation
and then you merge those two together
you also drain the dirty bath water of
the west
and you gain in doing so like a sorting
algorithm
separating the wheat from the chaff
merging those two together
you get what is potentially the greatest
expression of a civilization
that's possible to our
trajectory and
it's exciting because a lot of it does
have to do with this most
fundamental
neurochemical physiological
understanding
because
sovereignty in many ways
especially when living in a very
algorithmically
driven civilization where it feels like
a lot of the work is
hyper repetitive and also being
fed countless amounts of salt oil
and sugar and just being sedated and
gluttonous and scrolling on
social platforms without any motivation
that by potentially
undergoing a little bit of the
bio-optimizers while simultaneously
getting a little bit of self-discipline
maybe going on fast
going and bathing in the sun or the air
exercising sleeping better
pursuing entrepreneurship with more
vigor
that these sorts of
processes enable the anomalies
to fire and become
more celebrated as fireworks which is
which is really critical to actually
make sure that
the the social fabric
prospers so would it be fair then to say
that
there's a there's a propriet there's a
proprietary blend that has in a sense
been
molecularly formulated
iterated over and over and over again to
become optimized
to deliver a very specific
enhancement whether it's for the inward
or for the outward
sure but let's give relative context to
the listener here because i want to be
of
maximum utility and so
if we're looking at our experiential
reality as a human
and the the single
component of of the human organism or
the protoplasm is a single cell
so one would say that if we want to
maximize choice or prosperity of the
human experience we would want to be
able to have those cells to function in
its full range of capabilities
and in order to do that i said okay so
let's build some first principles
first okay so most of the world of
nutrition from which i have an extensive
background and experience in
uh us make the i think the fatal flaw
that your quality of life is first
determined
by the food selection they have and i
would say that's not accurate
i would say that there are principles
superior to that so if we look at the
functioning of that what makes a
cell function first and foremost we
should be able to determine
what is going to lead to get to these
products
and so one of the things that i do is i
give away my awesome health care
course so that people can set the
paradigm
first of how i have arrived
at the development of these things but
you can't supplement yourself out of a
poor
lifestyle and you need to apply first
principles first
in order to maximize the benefit of
these tools and i would say if if
resources have limited and they always
are to a certain extent for most people
and that is
whether it's time or energy those who
have the most
energy units available in the term of
dollars tend to have the least amount of
time
and those who have the least amount of
energy units as dollars seem to have the
most time it's an interesting paradigm
here in the west not shared in other
parts of the world
were abject poverty is where they have
no time like the
all of the time is just the struggle to
survive i mean just listen and
just go listen to um francis nagano's
story recently on
joe rogan and you can see what is the
actual reality for
billions of people on the planet his
story is truly remarkable
of his ability he's living in the modern
world but he
experienced abject poverty beyond
comprehension or you go to india
and he'll experience abject poverty so
we do have a certain
automatic capabilities of just being
winning the birth lotto being here in
the west and the foundational components
but when we go back to cellular
metabolism we can go well food is not
the primary factor because we can go
many months without
food so therefore what's more important
than food well
we can only go a few weeks maybe with
water without water
so water trumps food but if i were to
hold my breath here i would only go a
few minutes
therefore in orders of magnitude
before food we have air and water but if
i was to strap you
to the floor where you had no ability to
move
um the wasting away as anybody that's
seen anybody in the hospital is both
rapid and virtually every function of
the body from
cognition consciousness the
neurochemical happiness the movement to
physiological capabilities muscle
wasting
organ wasting all of that is pretty
accelerated if movement is part of it so
i would say that
air water and exercise the aspect of
movement because
the biggest aspect of technological
innovation
has been the restriction of movement
which which the biological organism has
a built-in refinement to preserve
energy for the durability and
procreation of the individual species
and technology was invented to limit the
amount of
of energy expenditure or acquired in
order to survive however we've taken
that to a step
so far that the technological
innovations are creating a sedentary
lifestyle
which are actually preventing us and
limiting the amount of energy that we
have and then the machines have now
created uh
biochemical inventions or interjections
into society which are further
uh disrupting our ability to access the
nutrients that give us the biochemical
range of possibilities
and so therefore i know that we live in
a solar system so i tend to look at
food as a condensed light as is
everything on the planet i'm a bit of a
physicist by nature uh it was kind of
certainly an intention and an
aptitude that i had more so than a
chemist actually
and so and when i created the philosophy
of how do we get to where we're going i
created
uh air water exercise and sunlight
basically the conversion of whatever it
is we are
consuming information sensory experience
and food because there's food for our
mind there's food for our soul
which are forms of frequencies i mean
the
and we can take any as a variety of
technological innovations and
and kind of see what joy resonates at
and love and
and all the way down to hate and anger
and disgust and all those on a frequency
domain
which is the conversion of sensory
experience into
physical realities with the cascade of
chemical reactions
so air water exercise and the
convergence of sunlight into the
appropriate arrange of
experiences will then lead us to the
cell
and at the cell we know this there are
a few things that make the cell work
better
because energy metabolism happens
through a force called
electron covalent transfer and the
efficiency of that in a mitochondria
which is actually an
integrated bacteria into the cell which
serves as a cellular membrane they
once separate and became concordant
and in existing in a symbiotic
relationship very much like our
microbiome
exists in a symbiotic relationship to
the protoplasmic mushroom we call
us so that's like margolis right so the
cell
is also equivalent to the whole organism
so we can extract from the cell
the things that optimize the cellular
function is the efficient conversion
of one thing into a stream of electrons
which produce
energy so if we were talking a car
engine if our mitochondria is like that
of a car
engine we could survive on a variety of
different fuels
we could burn diesel we could burn
gasoline we could build petroleum or
kerosene
or uh electric stored uh coal matter in
the form of electricity or the stored
wind or stole solar in the form of
electricity if we're running a tesla
unit which is
not quite yet to be used what is the
individual unit of the cell
30 trillion of them in the body what is
that individuated unit
using for energy is using polluted
sources of energy
right or really strong regenerative
sources right so we would say that the
the uh efficiency of the conversion of
that fuel
is going to determine how much waste
product is is produced and the waste
product
is what creates free radical damage or
the oxidative damage in the
and the mutation of the dna and
eventually leading to the inability for
that cell to replicate as it was
designed
and the advent of disease so how do we
address that
well we know that the things that
optimize the cellular function
our enzymes and probiotics are the only
thing that does the work in the body
they are the workers the converters the
things that build the
the house of our body that hook up the
electrical the plumbing
they hook up the conversion of the
energy
from the power grid into our bodies so
if we liken ourselves to a house
uh you know proteins carbohydrates fats
minerals and vitamins
are the equivalent of you know the the
wood
the steel the um
electrical wires you know the
plaster whatever you want to call it but
if you just
drove those all out to a site which is
what most
nutritional programs are advocating and
you had no workers to put it together
then then then you can't really build a
house you come back two weeks later the
house isn't built you need workers and
the amount of workers that you have
these converters will convert both
one form of energy into a usable form by
our biochemistry
and we'll convert the building blocks
into the subsequent matters that allow
us to build the body house
and so um by optimizers
became one of the biggest advocates of
first the conversion concept by
improving digestive aids of the
conversion
based on modern technology because our
definition of food didn't involve
made the assumption of conversion
without the knowledge of that and then
the second thing is we know that
uh essential amino acids essential fatty
acids
minerals vitamins are the com
and i would are the aspects that build
the body and then essential fuel sources
where they are carbohydrates and
right now it's in vogue to say that
carbohydrates are unnecessary
but i would say that um i would say
that's
i think that that carbohydrates may
contain
information packets very much like
proteins are very much like fats
which have a what you have a a array of
biochemical possibilities that are being
left behind thanks to dietary tribalism
and so i'm i'm i'm dietary agnostic
choose whatever
form works best for your genetics and
epigenetics and lifestyle in order to
convert those units
into the possible matrix of neural
chemicals
and building blocks to build your house
and offer the consciousness
possibilities
and then that leads you to the mind
which is mental beliefs and attitudes
and then how do you determine your
mental beliefs and attitudes well that's
largely in part by the group that you
inherited was around your tribal
dynamics if you will
whether that's digitally driven or you
know local
lies and we have a certain bigger array
of that now
than we ever have of possibility but we
also have the concordant aspect of
comparison which can paralyze people
and then the attitude i'm almost
finished but so how do we how do we
determine that we go to
the last piece of the formula which is
education testing and coaching
and education comes from the root word a
deuce
and to reduce you learn from within and
to learn
from within you run a test and the test
that you run will determine the outcome
and then
there's one piece to that which i call
the etc component which is a coach
is someone who has previously run a
variety of
tests and found some certain general
principles
that can cut the time uh cost
of running these experiments by saying
hey run
this these 10 15 20 experiments because
we know it leads you to a bet
a an optimal level choice aka the guru
right and that became the awesome health
formula air
water exercise sunlight optimizers
mental beliefs and attitude education
education testing and coaching
and we give that course a way to buy
optimize because that now leads
context in a process and a structure to
get to the point
where you'll get maximum value you could
take these product and get the benefits
but you won't
understand necessarily why and that's
fine for some people they don't care
they've got digestive pain they want
these enzymes it goes away
they can't digest their bowl of
spaghetti they take gluten guardian
they can't manufacture the neural
chemicals that make the thing they take
cognitive biotics
they got acid reflux or heartburn so
they take hydrochloric acid and
everybody takes that they get
they get every kind of infection known
to man so they take
a petrom and they don't get that anymore
they get rid of food poisoning
or that they find that now protein
doesn't sit like a
stone in their stomach or their food
doesn't sit and causes digestive
distress by taking mass times
and that was been the primary driver of
our
business right up until recently
where we got more involved in the
nervous system and
down regulation of the nervous system to
over stimulization which is the
development of magnesium
and then that led to the development of
our latest products in utopia
which is which is neurochemical
optimization to the point of
customization of the neural chemistry
that i want to access at a given time
based on my own unique chemistry and my
own ability to run
various stacks uh in nootropic
combinations to elicit the kind of
states that we want where we can
experiment with the variety of conscious
possibilities that
aren't accessible to someone who who
isn't able to manufacture or create the
well
of opportunities biochemically to allow
that to happen
boom boom yeah boom
love it that was so spot on
i love in awesome how focused the
first component is on the very
indigenous
understanding of naturopathy because
that is such a critical
aspect that is given our technologically
driven world like you indicated as being
sacrificed swept under the rug as not
important when it's actually the very
first principle
and then also the
as you broke down everything that it's
formulated itself
into on a biohacking level with bio
optimizers and now with newtopia which
we'll talk about here in a moment
i just wanted to share this really
interesting style like
visual recap of something that you were
talking about there
which was that in essence you kind of
have this
like the unhealthy fuel for the cell
which is the fundamental
unit there's 30 trillion of these in our
bodies the unhealthy fuel leads to
pathology
and the healthy fuel leads to
flourishing
and so really at the most kind of like
fundamental level
we're beginning to see that i
must be going out into
the air and breathing fresh air i have
to be bathing in the sun
i have to be moving my body i can't be
stuck
behind a computer for even more than 60
minutes at a time
i shouldn't be behind that device
without going for at least
five or ten minutes to go and walk and
stretch and do some push-ups and jumping
jacks and move around a bit
and
to recognize that everything that i'm
putting
in is an input everything is an input
all of what we just described as an
input and so is the information that we
take in
get yourself away from the frequencies
of polarization propaganda
and of the mass media garbage and get
yourself to the vibrational frequencies
of enlightenment and get yourself to the
vibrational frequencies like we talked
about with
gurus coaches people that have actually
been there and done that whether it be
on the path of enlightenment inward
or whether it be with the
entrepreneurship and the art expression
outward to be able to find those
optimize those efficiencies for oneself
and to recognize that the fuel that we
put in
information wise is also amplifying or
contracting our choice architectures
and so whether it be informational fuel
or whether it be biotech fuels
or whether it be basic foods that we
take in waters that we drink
the amount of sleep that we get if we
choose to move our bodies
or not throughout the day and that then
translates directly
into how well our cells
function and how well we
are able to be more
anomalous versus conformist
and so just all of this ties together so
brilliantly across these maps and it's
and i love that i want to ask about the
about the both within
bio optimizers and with newtopia i want
to ask
about
obviously having such a a breadth and a
catalog
and also around with newtopia being able
to sort of take this
this at a personalized level is it a
i think when we talked it was a 300 a
month subscription
is that right well that's if you want a
full array of we have
eight different uh nootropic
formulations
each one of those when someone
engages in newtopia they can go for
three different levels depending but
let's just go to the
end degree yeah you can we can talk
about some of those right now so
what the let's just deal with the
fundamental
issue that has happened with most
nootropics
so most nootropics to the development
today are are in two different levels
there's the pharmacologically developed
uh cognitive enhancers which have
proliferated the ivy league institutions
and
large corporate entities which high
threshold pressure
due to technological innovation require
those have traditionally things like
adderall modafinil
blah blah blah blah all down that line
and then the
pathological components would be
everything that's been array
been been invented and developed in
order to stabilize
uh a functional human being through
pharmacological intervention through
psychiatry and psychology and that's a
whole other issue i'm not gonna address
that one i'm going to go to
optimization with the assumption that
you're at a a baseline that is
seemingly functional in the world today
um
so we know that if we were to examine
your
chemistry versus my chemistry there
would be some unique components so
as a child of the 80s if you can
remember those old synthesizers
which had all the different bells you
know the mids and the trebles and the
bases and the left and the right and the
center channel and all that sort of
stuff so you can imagine that
that uh that display
as the neurochemical potential and
possibility that one exists and there's
dominance
so some people like bass some people
like treble
so when you go to
uh one of the great greats in the
performance world
uh the strength sensei charles poliquin
who left this
plane much too early he was the first
person to my awareness that was able to
make the connection between
chinese medicine and neurochemical
dominance there was no
bridge between western pharmacological
science and chinese medicine
and both condemned each other quite
consistently and he
found the bridge and with his high
performance athletes who were subjected
to
extraordinary levels of stress he found
first off he determined that the basic
neurochemical dominance whether it was
acetylcholine or doma
or dopamine particularly were concordant
with
the ability to perform at high levels of
olympic level in fact in fact he said
if if you took a braverman test which is
a basic test you can
turn it neurochemical dominance um he he
had said
you know if you weren't dopamine or
acetylcholine he never even bothered
training you because you're probably an
artist or some aspect of society because
and not to discredit those people but
from his world he was on a performance
oriented
but it led me to believe what is the
neurochemistry of creativity what is the
neural chemistry of
artistry because i think a life well
dopamine or acetylcholine based what is
it
what is it right so maybe it's serotonin
maybe it's gaba
right there's all these race well turns
out
there's about eight dominant types of
neurotransmitters that are
go in a various arrays inside our body
and we may through diet
or restriction or inability to convert
be limited in some of those so
people's range of human expression or
possibility or creativity
is one related to neural connectivity
and
other related to neural chemical cascade
and we all know people
who were maybe very at the top of their
game at a certain part in life
but then there's a slow degeneration
for a variety of reasons okay and we
call that the aging and degeneration
process
and so we looked at that and said well
what if we can what if we can use
technology
to inject and optimize specific
neurochemical
combinations that a person can
self-select through a strategic process
so that they can start altering their
chemistry so i'll give you an example
right
so take this is a kind of a fun one that
matt and i
we used to engage in a variety of things
we called the zamner zone
that's a whole story in itself but you
take this here right
and we know that the array of
elements that we've put in this bottle
uh
leave some of those yeah that lead to a
neural chemical
so i go like this right
and what and give us some of them also
of the elements put
in to the formula as much as you are
free to feel free to share
i won't share that proprietary
information in the context of this
but what i will say that right now i can
instantly feel
a shift in my neural chemical
cognitive capability right now
okay i've just i've just used it
bottled technology to shift
my neural chemistry
what makes this different than say a
drug
is that a drug is going to have a
certain amount of negative free radical
residues that our body is going to have
to process which
lead to a set maybe sometimes a higher
peak
but a continuous degeneration and an
eventual dependency
what we've developed is compounds
of an organic nature because it turns
out when you do the chemistry
that the better the extract and the
cleaner the organics that and the source
materials
the better the concordant result and the
in as opposed to
being a limited stimulative effect which
most nootropics are just pounding the
nervous system
what this is is filling up the bucket of
neural chemicals
so that you can access it for an
extended period of time and there seems
to be
a buildup over time as you
fill up what was an empty reservoir of
neurochemicals and so what i would
suggest that people in the world today
that aren't experiencing the full array
of possible as a human
aspect you can shift this
by using newtopia products
in a way that allows us to fill up
the uh deficient
neural chemicals that have res have been
a result
of the last 80 years of depletion of the
materials and the conversion
factors that allow us to manufacture
those which lead to expansion
we can go into that right away i got
through this whole process of the
awesome formula and the organics and the
dietary and the conversion process and
all these elements but newtopia is kind
of the pinnacle of that development
where we go straight to the
neurochemistry itself
now for some people they may want to go
down that route first
to give credence to what we did before i
happen to go through this
kind of pedestrian process
and so our team has been able to put
these together
and uh the results are anybody who is
reliant
on their brain to produce results in the
world
um if you so if you make a living with
your brain or you require
thinking and i would say that in a
technologically advanced world that is a
very very dominant your
your your ability to the more that
you're able to come up with great ideas
or
efficient ideas or value creation ideas
the more valuable your time energy and
the more energy units that you get in
the form of money and remuneration and
friends and possibilities
then i think in a technological world it
gives you a biochemical edge that allows
you to expand
and leverage the advantage of technology
without being a victim of said
technology
so that's what we do and so the things
that you were showing there for example
um you know things like uh if you look
at
we've got upbeat which is a neural
combination which is associative to
feeling up you know that feeling that
you're feeling upbeat and positive and
you know with a positive nature over
here we've got things like the power
solution which is
kind of like almost uh if you're lacking
in drive
in uh i would say aggressively attacking
that which it is that's probably a good
option for you
there's another one which is a little
softer there which is nectar rx which is
uh i would say a lighter form
of drive and stimulation so that you can
maintain focus and attention
we got things like brain flow which is a
is a neural chemical can
consistent with being in the flow state
and then we have a you know like another
one i think we call it we i don't think
i have it here i think it's actually in
there somewhere i put it in the bag i
didn't bring the actual box which is
focus savagery which is like you know
maybe you're writing a book or
working on a musical composition or have
a paper do
you would use that for a hyper focus
there's other ones like zamner juice for
example
which is really great and being
connected and socially and how often can
you also
hit well it's going to be so there's
another piece to this puzzle
because each person's capabilities to
manage
tolerate and optimize are going to vary
a significant amount
and so what we've done is people fill
out a form
and in that form they're kind of given
some predispositions about their work
their lifestyle what they're going to do
which is going to indicate
neurochemical dominance we manufacture
a customized blend in the variance of
these possibilities to that individual
and then they give the feedback to our
chemists
that allows them to tweak the
formulation based on their experience
they're like ah you know that was a
little too intense i want to dial that
back
i didn't feel that much on this one so
can we expand that one
and there's you know about uh a sigma
uh in to the left or to the right
of the baseline formulation that will
probably account for 90 of the
population's
neural chemical possibilities and one of
the things that we do it by optimizers
because we
uh disperse these to all of the people
that work for our companies when we
start our meetings is like okay what's
your stack today
and what's really interesting just even
in our in our in you know in our
small and connected company the
the variance within the group of people
that we work together is
wildly different there are some patterns
that we have seen
that seem to be most concordant for
people would like
as far as you know some people one of
the more popular
ones is brain flow and and the
nectar x those two are probably the most
common ones
and and that people seem to get the best
or most
effective results relative to work but
then there's the apex
and brain flow and xamarin juice and so
depending on what your role is
you're going to experience different
things from different products and so
what this
offers is a cornucopia
of customized nootropic blends which
have baseline
aspects and then you get to stack each
one of those
to your own symphony to essentially make
the own music for your own mind
and yeah that's where we've kind of just
completely obliterated the nootropic
conversation over and above anything
that's been created pharmacologically
and anything that's been created in the
nutrition field from a nootropic blend
and
uh fortunately the the chemist that we
we we're working with has done an
extraordinary job of doing this and it's
our job to get this out to the masses
because i think the only way out of the
matrix
is through biochemical optimization to
realize that we don't have to follow the
choices of conformity which are being
propagated upon the population i see how
this relates on a
metaphysical level consciousness level
biochemical level
see if i can hit the ball with a good
synthesis here from the beginning of our
conversation until now
so it seems as though as we both talked
about this
being an appearance of infinity
expressing itself
in that all of the different
possibilities as you gave with the music
example which we frequently give on the
show as well
is that you can never come to the end of
all of the different combinations of
musical notes and so this
is an infinite symphony in this song
this appearance is a song
unit verse one song and so
in an endless amount of songs and so
within the appearance of form that is
this
song that
there is this wade lightheart character
in this atlas character and all these
characters that are watching the program
and that all of these characters have a
very unique
not only neurochemistry and physiology
but also they have a unique
style of union with
source and they have a unique style of
expression like a firework
outward as well in a very non-conformist
style way
but rather in a very expressionary
individuated
gift-oriented style way and so now
that appearance of form comes as
another in a sense musical combination
where you're your own song
and i'm my own song and that's its own
unique
neurochemistry and physiology that then
with newtopia there's sort of a process
of being able to pay
in on a monthly basis to be able to
access the personalization
to my unique biochemistry that then
enables me to even work with
the chemists work with the formulators
on the process of tweaking
the formulations in both directions and
sort of regaining that sovereignty that
choice architecture that we were talking
about
yeah so for the first time ever the
individual
consumer is able to be a participant
in the optimization of their own biology
based on their
own tests so we essentially take turn
over
manufacturing control
to you the individual
so that you self-select and run your own
set of experiments on your own neural
chemistry
and here's the best part not only do you
get to pull the levers and dials to your
own
make your own music so to speak your own
mental music
but we de-risk the entire experiment by
saying
if after your first month you're not
completely
enamored with both the results in the
process
we'll refund every cent that you paid to
us
and if you'd like the song to continue
to go
we'll keep the supply of of notes
so that you can play the symphony that
you so desire and we
encourage you to provide us that
feedback because it allows us to develop
a a larger cascade of of of
other instruments to play for the for
the for for the band of your mind if you
will and
and that to me has
invigorated my experience
and why i'm so passionate about sharing
this with people
because over just the last six months
not only has by optimizers and utopia
uh caused a rapid expansion of our
business
but the expansion of human
uh experiences on an individual basis
for everyone who's participated in this
process
has been amplified geometrically as well
and so what that means is to me
is that hey we're on to something it's a
great movement it may be a breakthrough
moment
for biological organisms and we are
inviting people who are excited by that
idea to participate
in the emergence of
a greater sense of neurological control
and
neurological possibilities by amplifying
this and of course there's other people
in the biohacking space that's using
neural feedback
like you know dave asprey and 40 years
of zen i'm a big advocate of that or
biocybernaut and and some of the other
neural feedback systems that are out
there which
allow you to alter the the neural
physiological connections so
going back to the architecture of that
what we provide
is the chemicals to allow for a greater
uh sea of possibilities from a neural
chemical perspective so that
you might be so inclined to develop new
skills or new abilities or
optimize the ones that you have or all
those sort of things so we're just
early into this journey and we're in
we're inviting people
who think hey this is a great idea i'd
like to play on that experimental origin
to contact our company and we'll hook
you up and you can experience what you
want to experience
and so there's a promo code
in the bio of the video
it's simulation
10 all lowercase simulation 10.
and you can use that on by
optimizers.com
and what you can what you can do is you
can go to checkout
enter in the promo code you get 10 off
and on bio optimizers you can pick up
the you know the myriad products
that that wade was teaching us about
and also is the
newtopia subscription available also on
bio yeah and that's a very limited
amount at this stage because
we're only gonna our manufacturing
capabilities
is limited at this point to make this
level of quality and this isn't this
isn't like
this isn't like a a marketing hype of
hey you know there's a scarcity thing
pitch here that is a that is a
manufacturing biochemical reality so
we have at least for now at least for
now at this at this stage
um and when they make an order of that
we also provide a couple of other things
one
and how do they make an order of that uh
they just they just go to the website
and they can
they'll they'll be able to find it and
access it and there's a specific
place on the site yeah we'll we'll put
the links into the okay
okay yeah all right so you can find
newtopia
also on bio optimizer yeah and
particularly the biological optimization
blueprint
will kind of give the framework that
matt and myself the co-founders of the
company use to the application of the
general sense that we talked about we
give the awesome health digital course
and then we have also available to
people who participate in this with
newtopia
yeah because that order is a high enough
margin so if you order products at a i
think it's over 150 bucks or something
you get the blueprint
so the 300 or so a month price point is
solely for the personalization but then
on top of that
is the payment for the actual product
you get the products and everything you
get the whole
enchilada and that yeah and that's
enough to you you get the you get to
play the neural chemical game every day
of the month
they're a step down a 200 and a hundred
dollar roughly program
that's all ten dollars ten dollars a day
is nothing
it's a joke yeah it's an absolute it's
actually
it's it's fantastic and i've yet to have
anyone who hasn't
who hasn't tried even the lowest forms
to scale up to the maximum program and
say okay i'm in i love this
and so you know it's really exciting for
us as a company and to be in this
position
where i believe that providence
has put me in the position where i can
be an advocate for this because i've
been a consciousness researcher for so
long i've been a health advocate
advocate for aesthetics and performance
and health virtually my entire life
and suddenly as we are faced with what i
would call biochemical extermination
that providence has provided these tools
and i do believe that
it's quite possible that this is
an adaptive response so
up until this point
um the environmental factors
have been the driver of darwinian
evolution
right there's been external factors but
what's interesting with technological
innovation
humans themselves have become
the the
stimulus for mutation or adapt
the forced adaptation to a technological
world so we've innovated so much over
the last eight years and removed
ourselves from normal
uh our natural existence for millions of
years
that i believe that homo sapiens are now
going through a mutation phase where
we're going to have like
you know homo digitalis and homo
spiritus
and homo genetic you know
geneticists where people are and then
you know
we're all sort of a cybernetic organism
you know with their attachment to
technology and so we have all these
variants
that is that is happening and and some
of those experiments are going to work
out and some of those are going to be
breakaway
dominant ones just like if you go to
yuval noah
or noah yuval hirari's books on on
sapiens and homodeus and 21 lessons for
the 21st listener
i think he's listed two binary kind of
options i think there's a little bit
more of an array there
and this is one of the potential
possibilities
that i think that allows us to adapt to
uh aggressively changing circumstances
that
will potentially engage the survival of
the next generations to come
so from my perspective and hopefully
democratize the costs even more to
enable more people that don't have their
basic needs even being met in the
developed world even in the developed
world to be able to access the
new topia style technologies to enhance
themselves
as we're talking about yeah so it's
which the early adopters do end up
making the democratization downstream
which is great
yeah and then and that's the thing and
so one
it's kind of goes back to the the old
story of the talents
whatever you are given whether it's one
talent three talents five talents
whether you
are born rich or poor or super
intelligent or not super intelligent
you you you get the hand that you've
been played
and you play that hand to the best of
your ability
and providence has put me in this
position
and so i feel it is my moral ethical
duty not only to this generation but for
the generations to come
to provide this as a risk-free
opportunity
for people to experience and see if it's
for them and they want to see
how deep the rabbit hole goes and and i
and i i remove
any sense that they need to stay
committed to it
or i remove the risk of it you know and
and and leave them with the possibility
of choice and if that works for them
continue on and share it with others and
if it doesn't work for them thank you
for the experiment
continue on with your experiments and if
you have something of value that you can
share with me hey i'm up for that too
in many ways this is this
2020s these roaring 20s
are the
playground in a sense for the evolution
of
artificial general intelligence bio and
neurotech
and decentralization and
cryptocurrencies and
the inclusive equity that we can do in
our smart contracts in our
mechanism design that then enable the
shared equity enthyagens
these enlightenment pedagogies that can
be brought to
the billionaires of the planet and the
fortune 500
ceos and the u.n general assembly and
the u.s congress and all this type of
stuff
where more and more from the top
down at the same time from the bottom up
we can enlighten
and enrich ourselves and create a
inclusive equity into the actual social
contracts
around us in society to where
we don't even have to necessarily
although it's really
the story of all of these different
possibilities around
oh my gosh you know elysium and
all these other catastrophic scenarios
or versus the ones where it's a little
bit less
catastrophic or where it's just you know
utopia
and so there's a very
much a possibility space here in this
decade and beyond
where we by doing things like what we've
been talking about with bio-optimization
and optimizing ourselves both in the
inward trajectory and the outward
trajectory
you know we become the ones that undergo
the process of recognizing that the more
that we
enable larger choice matrixes
and more maximizing human potential and
more flourishing
more enlightenment and less ego
the more that there will be less
suffering the more that there will be
more
abundance and more flourishing and
that's going to be a critical component
of these next couple of decades
and that's sort of the connecting thread
in a sense between
everything that we talk about from
metaphysics and consciousness and
enlightenment
all the way in the dissolving of the ego
all the way out to the unique expression
of each individuation and not
destroying that via conformity but
rather enabling the uniqueness
the individuation to flower and flourish
as a brilliant
scent from each flower of us expressed
and that that
is the symphony unfolding in this
expression
and to never
turn down the music of the flower's
expression or to never
to only be focused on helping the
musical expression of each individuation
become more
in tune rather than out of tune or
to help increase the volume of the
flowers that are blossoming
with their unique aromas rather than
trying to you know squelch them
and so you know these styles of
analogies and metaphors in this entire
process
sort of help with the with the
visualization of what's going on on
across all of these levels and layers
and
that you're one of the many
components
and you're doing it at the level of the
of the neurochemistry and the physiology
which is a
huge huge huge component
and
you tell a story to somebody about a
blank
canvas and that blank canvas having an
infinite amount of ways that you can
take colors and paint on it
and within potentially a couple of
minutes of conversation and
contemplation the person can recognize
themselves as an expression of infinity
and stop seeking happiness
externally and being a bubbled up
ego and pop dissolve that
so a story can be a catalyst
a biochemical experience
on a daily basis can be a catalyst all
of these different catalysts that exist
in order to maximize prosperity maximize
those choice architecture
yeah and and i think right now we're in
the convergence of two ideologies in
this i'm not really sure what you mean
by equity and i'm always
mindful when people just i'll just i'll
just briefly explain yeah
just shared equity in the sense of
inclusive stakeholding
in the sense of having a
a social contract given tokenomics and
smart contracts that enable us to do
things like this where
the as silicon valley did about 30 years
ago or so which was that
okay now it's not just about
shareholders extracting
maximal finances and that being it which
still is relevant today which we're
trying to fix perverse incentives
but that silicon valley said that hey
guess what we're actually going to give
our employees
equity that's vested on cliffs every
single year
that was one step towards shared equity
or inclusive stakeholding
and then there's many steps as well
within that process
that actually maximize human potential
and eradicate
suffering and meet basic needs across
the planet
to make communities and environments
and even customers even given tokens
even minor uh stakeholders in the
equation
yeah and i i have a bit of concern with
that because
i think the attraction of those concepts
are are very real from an intellectual
perspective but the
actual expression of those have given
off opposition
so if you look at the techno tyranny
that is inverged out of those concepts
in the form of algorithmic dominance of
your thought process
and the canceling of those which differ
from the founders of that idea
and the concepts of these equity and
we're going to do this for the good of
the population makes a large assumption
that i know what's best for the
population and i think the ultimate
goal of the western mind was the
development of the the
the ultimate autonomy is the the the
individual itself
and that individual is responsible
um to play the cards that it that it's
handed
and i think that when you centralize
thought
and you centralize control
which tends to happen with technological
innovation
then the potential to actually
uh oppress or suppress it grows
exponentially which we witnessed
with the rise of marxist philosophy in
the soviet union and we saw it being
repeated
also in you know in in china
where a very small segment of the
population dominates a large part with
there's a those those models
historically have produced the biggest
gap
and so i think that uh local
um localized programs where
you connect with the community members
within your immediate field that you
have the expression to
is superior to centralized control
so yeah so and then that's where and
what happens is now we have these
we have the politicization
we haven't even played yet with we
haven't even played yet with what i'm
talking about
yeah so yes and expand on that it's just
what's coming through this expression of
infinity is
basically what infinity is screaming
at us to do that
enables a synthesis of
both the individuation with the robust
anti-fragile social contracts and social
fabric itself
it's merging both the best of both
together and draining the dirty bath
water of both
because over and over again people go
100 million deaths in the 20th century
100 million deaths in the 20th century
very important dirty bath water archive
that code it's
it's where we've learned we're moved on
we're not doing any of those codes
anymore
individuation has its own perverse
incentives as well
when you have an egoic individual
running a fortune 500 company
you're having somebody that has the
tendency to seek happiness in the
purchasing
of a fifth yacht or your 20th designer
purse or whatever it is
rather than recognizing that the
investment into the
employees at the company their health
and wellness the community that the
company's actually located in
all this type of stuff if you're more of
an enlightened state so
it's well there's an assumption though
there's an assumption there
which i think has been propagated by um
uh movies and politicization that the
person who's the head of the fortune 500
company is operating from that parameter
of self-interest
uh exclusively and only their gain over
the dominance of others and i don't
think that's true totally
and i'm not trying to make it a binary
saying it's a hundred percent i'm just
saying that
there is 2 200 billionaires on the
planet
the first target of enlightenment on the
planet
should be the analysis biometrically
of the egoic to enlighten state
of said 2 200 people because
most of those people control most of the
operations of the planet
and they meet at davos every single year
sure well if you're talking about the
world economic forum and what's being
disseminated there i think there's very
big challenges that are happening so
generally speaking generally speaking
there is no
binary saying that this group of people
are the malevolent ones period
in this group of people are the ones
that are the most victim period
it's always going to be a blend of both
and yet we recognize that the
most upstream issue that infinity is
screaming to us
is that if you want to get past your
fermi filters
the thing that you have to do is you
have to recognize your own nature
you have to know yourself you have to
know thy source you have to know
what you truly are which is that you're
all an expression of the same source
and that your awareness your
consciousness is shared in its eternal
and that your unique individuation
is also critical and so
that style of know thy self all the way
in all the way out
is what infinity screaming make the
proper
choice architectures in that execution
and get past your great filters and get
to the next
the snakehead eating its tail the
oroboros yeah and and
i it would appear that
the challenge of technologically
advanced civilizations if we look from a
historical spect is they tend to
exterminate themselves so there seems to
be
some sort of consciousness reset
is that when there's a disproportion it
happens that there's some sort of
non-linear event which causes the
destruction of that
civilization and going back to when i
said i experimented with the rise and
fall
of civilizations and their cascade of
values and ideas which i've been running
that experiment for three and a half
years
come to the conclusion for myself that
i would rather provide
options for people to express
whatever whatever form of expression
they want to whatever degree
and leave it at that as opposed the the
idea to seek dominance over others
and conform it to my own ideas and
that's why that's why i always
with our company we always provide the
option of
if you don't like the choice you opt out
and we refund your energy credits if you
will totally totally
so that you go back and and choose
another experiment yeah we recognize
that the ego
we recognize that that which
propagates the essence of
seeking and trying to extract happiness
and extract it from the relationships or
substances
or material possessions or
greed or whatever it is we recognize
although what you just said a moment ago
is so true
which is your ethos of optimizing from
the individuated perspective
so true so important and yet to not
throw away the consensus style truth
that infinity can make about
itself which is that the egoic levels of
consciousness that are in positions
especially of power
around the planet is in fact our most
upstream
problem to tackle yeah um
although i don't think that everything
can be put through the deterministic
level of of of power and i think that's
uh it's consciousness more so i think i
think there's a dangerous political
less power it's more cautious yeah and i
think but there's
there's this this this kind of theme
that's going out into the world today
about power dynamics and
agreement i remember first learning
about this in university
25 years ago with the idea of hegemony
that there's
a small group of people in power and
there's a large people group of people
that don't have it and there's a smoke
screen between the two
and i can tell that you're very much a
you have you have a you have a
perspective that you're continuing to
share
which i have a very strong presence on
and i try with our channel to actually
go
because it's it's almost like in a sense
a classic
like conversation that happens so
frequently between individuality and
collectivism and all this type of stuff
what would i try to reiterate several
times
is let's go to where we take the best
from both and merge them together into
one
yeah which i think is maximal choice
with minimal invasion to the
to the individual so i would say that
i'm
a constructive libertarian
from the perspective is that i i
wish to liberate people from a
biochemical prison
that they are in due to the unintended
consequences of technological innovation
and i'm going to make the assumption
that those
consequences were not of a conspiratory
nature they were i just merely the
unintended consequences of
rapid innovation and technicalization
and
that i would be very mindful about
dictating
my ideas to other people in a way that
makes them feel that they
they can somehow shirk their own
responsibility to play the cards they
have
and play a victim of something else and
so
um and and as long as you're not
disrupting
physical existence of other people
then i think it's good so that where
does the line draw
i i believe the line draws in violence
right um violence
is a form of communication and it's a
communication
that is recognized by everyone
everywhere regardless of language
it would i would say it's probably the
lowest form
of communication the most base form of
communication
and the second tier of that
is the threat of violence if you don't
conform to my ideal
or the threat of restriction
in the form of possibility because
you're not adhering to the the rules of
the game as i set forth
and i think if we were to find common
ground
the there's never been a situation in
history
where so few could hold the levers of
of disseminating those ideals
onto so many which goes to the thought
of well
power corrupts and absolute power
corrupts absolutely
and so maybe
the homo sapien
the the jump in consciousness is can we
cross
the nuclear threshold which is
the potential extermination of all life
on this planet or most of it
or the artificial intelligence threshold
can we transcend that without booting up
the
extermination of the species and then if
you go to the elon musk version is
well if if survival in the continuous
evolution of the species
is going to happen we need to be become
an exo species and be able to leave
this planet and it and it's our
dependency on the
environmental components that give birth
to life
and consciousness in physical expression
on this planet and i think
right now we're running over a multi
amount of those experiments and we're
now consciously aware of in
as individuals to the grand magnitude of
all these
thanks to technological intervention
is that now i can see what the world
economic forum's up to
i can see what the people in washington
are up to
i can see what elon musk is up to i can
see
what google and facebook and amazon
whether and and or i can look through
all these different lenses
simultaneously
and i would say that for the most part
many of humans are simply overwhelmed
with the paradigm of information
and are becoming paralyzed
through a voyeuristic observation of
life
and have forgotten to participate
as a biological organization to the
point of
i'm walking down the street here the
other day without a mask on
and an individual who i've never met
before with his dog
just walks by me and gives me the finger
right or we see people attacking each
other violently or destroying
property because of a political idea
or we see people and a discriminatory
nature because
of the uh assigning
values based on how much melanin is
is in his person's skin and so what i
would see in the modern world
is the product that is being put out
there in the world is division
and if that's the product then
we need to manufacture a different
product
and the current the current
uh uh situation that we're kind of plays
ironically into unity
it does it well it does and then the
thing is is what we're to merge the two
together unity and
individuation that is the point correct
and
and how do we find the balance in in a
in a hyper technologically advanced
world and i would say if
we address the issue
as a victim perpetrator kind of
mentality we're in deep deep deep
trouble
if we just see that we're participants
in this movie
of humanity as an individual component
and then we can listen
and actually hear that person and that
person
doesn't feel the need to validate their
existence
through the condemnation or exclusion of
someone else
then we've got something to go for but
at the end of the day
um biology leads to
uh competency and efficiency
and and that is something that none of
us can get out of and they're of course
environmental influences
you know the reason that i believe a lot
of things that i believe in the
experiences i have is because where i've
been born
and the values that have been inculcated
into my belief systems
if i was born in another part of the
planet in another part of the world and
in a different environment i would think
something totally differently
and so in this rapid awareness of
of of the extensive potential
of human possibilities and
it's gory detail
you know or it's gory glory um
and the sheer going back to the hawkins
scale of consciousness which i think is
the best approximation of
of the human condition that we can find
is that
there is spiral there amex is pretty
good too
this is very the law of one there are
several others in
yeah ballpark that that provide a really
strong
model for the nature of reality
it's like yeah it's like this we've
brought it up on the show
quite a bit before let's put it on six
yes you have the hawkins in the bottom
left corner
you have the spiral dynamics of claire
graves and
chris cowan and don beck ken wilbur in
the bottom right corner yeah
then you have what is the law of one
channeled by raw the seven density model
of consciousness
in the top right corner and these
sort of ideas
you know an even top left infinity
expressing itself these sort of ideas
synthesized together give a very strong
in a sense like a phd in metaphysics
to study all of them and from there
we can recognize that the most upstream
is enlightenment enlightenment is the
key it's the most important service we
can render humanity and if we can hack
our biology and augment our ability to
go inward more
efficiently and outward more efficiently
it's going to be a critical
role and then or and i think a realistic
goal
for all of us as a as a because we have
to find where is the accountability
for myself what's that what's the
accounting am i moving towards that
direction
and i would say the approximation that
one
puts through the filter of their actions
from a position of
am i expressing love
love seems to be the binding
factor and so
even if i enjoy peace right if i if i
don't agree
with a person or an idea or a concept
am i able to share my disapproval of
that
in a way that is empathetic and loving
or do i have to resort to a violent
nature and if i resort to a violent
nature
i would say the accountability of my own
uh my it
tells me that i'm off track right
because we know
that the absence of love at its highest
level leads to violence and
one of the things that i'm fascinated by
in expression
is the ufc which has been proliferated
recently in sports which is a
communication form that we all
understand people love close quarter
combat because it's so action-packed
yes but what's fascinating is you'll
have
two of these individuals guys or girls
literally trying to tear the other
person apart and oftentimes
at the end of
the action they're just like yeah they
embrace each other
yeah because there's an aspect that they
were able to survive that person's best
component
and and you know the olympic spirit
which i really believe is that oh i see
what you're doing by making a
juxtaposition between
that and cancel culture which can't
handle the giving of fists
right after the fight right right and
that's the difference
is that hey we can engage in a
discussion in a comp
competition of ideas and we agree upon
the rules that that is that allows the
individual autonomy provided it's not
causing damage to society itself
no violence no but we've got to get we
gotta you know
we gotta drop the violence it's totally
true it's the lowest form like you said
of course right
and i would say the non-voluntary
violence
if two people decide they agree
that they want to have a duel get in a
fist fight
kill each other as an individual
individual manoa mano woman and woman or
whatever you want to call that
if that's what those two individuals
choose as a is as an option for them
go for it i i i'm not going to intervene
my way inside of that but when i have
a singular or group of people exerting
violence onto an individual or group
that wasn't agreed upon then i think
that's where we need to draw the line
and violence can come
form uh in its most subtlest act in the
form of ideologies
and and and uh per perspective
i think there was a great article a book
that's been
just i was just reviewing the other day
which is parasitical ideas by
saad who is talking about how
ideas can infect the human
organism as humanity itself which have
very very dire consequences and
in in this ability to proliferate ideas
in a way
exponentially that we never have before
and the ability to destroy ourselves
it's it's i think the individual
accounting system
should be can i come from a position of
love
is my communication in love yeah and
and and in empathy and compassion for
that even which i'm ab horribly against
um can i do so in that way buddhahood is
the ultimate metric
yeah the awakened one is love
it radiates that it radiates peace
it radiates equal equanimity it radiates
joy
yeah it radiates aw and then it
butterfly affects that out to everything
that it touches
and so that first principle going all
the way in know thyself
and like you said also have accountable
stacks of markers that indicate one's
progress all the way inward leverage
biohacking techniques
also outward yeah express the unique
individuation
let's uh let's let's wrap um
yeah that was so fun it's a fun it's a
fun thing because
it's ridiculous yeah it's really great
you would that was so fun
wow i mean yeah we covered a ridiculous
amount in there
and just you know this is one of the
things that i love about
polymaths is that when you've learned
much across
a lot of different disciplines and
you've been able to you know as charlie
munger says
you hang up everything that you've
learned from these core disciplines into
this gorgeous lattice work
and then as warren buffett says you just
gain compound interest which is the
eighth wonder of the world
on that beautiful latticework over time
yeah i think elon musk has i was just
reading a quote from the other day is
that
you you hold maybe a dozen
really complex problems in your life or
human existence
in mind all the time and then when you
garner new information from a field you
you take that eureka moment and then you
apply it to those 12 things
or 10 things and see if there's a
breakthrough and
that's something that i think i've
attempted to embrace
on on a minuscule level in the world of
biological optimization and what we do
at by optimizers which i i love and but
also spiritually geopolitically
absolutely and i draw from those things
so our our primary
mission in the company is to end
physical suffering and
activate biologically optimized health
and so our whole premise is to help move
people out of
sickness disease and the the
the loss of possibility to moving to a
state of
first and functionality and then up the
ladder
into optimization and then biologically
you know like super health and super
capabilities
so the expansion of awareness and
choices and possibilities
exceed that which is based in survival
mechanisms where one is so stressed that
the organism can't sustain due to the
outward pressures and i think that's a
great goal for
all of us and whatever format that we're
doing whether
we're making food for our family whether
we're laboring in the world and
making sure that the power stays on and
the roads stay plowed or
you know the the sanitation facility
works
or that the food gets delivered at the
restaurant or and if we
all take whatever job that we are at in
life
and we do it to the best of our ability
to and take the hand that i got and just
do the best job that i get so if i'm
sweeping the floor i'm going to sweep it
to the best
and i'm going to have joy in that then
we feel a deeper connection and i think
the
vast array of consciousness
possibilities
become activated not by our outward
expression in the world but our inward
commitment
to that which i find myself in this
moment
to the best of my ability because you
know the human condition is quite tragic
and is is is it's suffering
is unavoidable but if you can find it
it's meaningful and exploratory if you
can find
meaning out of the suffering you have
these glimpses
of the beautific possibilities
and and therefore when one comes to the
moment of life
of one's own death the the cessation
of physical existence itself one can
rush into the abyss not s
you know fearful as a sheep yeah but
celebrating it
into the immersion of the infinite and
saying
what a great expression that was yeah to
to to you know
and and and it and and take the last
best
and the drop dissolves into the ocean
of bliss yep sat [ __ ] ananda
sachit ananda boom wait this was such a
blast
boom i love it wade lightheart everyone
consciousness metaphysics biochemistry
check out the link in the bio below to
bio
optimizers.com you can use the promo
code simulation 10 for 10
off check out all of the different
products that they have to offer
also check out newtopia as well get
your personalized
augmentations delivered to you and work
with the chemist
on the process beautiful stuff and
also if the podcast brought you value
hit the subscribe button like the video
help us out with the youtube algorithm
leave a comment below with your thoughts
we'd love to hear
from you also if you'd like
share the podcast with other people that
you feel like would gain
from it we covered so many epic topics
together
so do share it with people that it
resonate with
and join the channel if you'd like to
gain
exclusive perks and benefits and in
doing so we will funnel
every single dollar into the
actualization of all of our great
projects out here in los angeles and
beyond
we have a lot of great things cooking
for you
and that is all
that's all wade thanks for having me
it's a true
such trip thanks brother
we crushed it oh man wade's got a
an awesome community of people that he
surrounds himself with out here in
in venice and he's invited me over
several times and it's been such a blast
so many more co-creations coming you
betcha
pumped pumped much love everyone thank
you for tuning in we will see you soon
peace